how are you doing i'm good how are you
two training two chains i'm steve
nice to meet you nice to meet you
[Music]
we are here in the city of sin las vegas
right
that's a lot of people trying to get
married and do it in their own
personalized way
so when i heard about smile cloud i
heard it was like this way that people
propose
express their love etc etc yes sir so
what we have is
this is a biodegradable soap solution
mixed with water
is that touchable when you say
biodegradable it means you can
put your message up in the sky and
you're not harming anything
big thing that we have is people that
don't want to do balloon releases
anymore i mean it's illegal in a lot of
places i had no idea yeah yeah
because of the wildlife where'd you get
that idea from
uh asia really yep i was looking for
something new to do
corporate burnout found this thing and
brought it to
north america and been rolling with it
ever since can you give me a yeah an
introduction to your machine i've never
met her before
right right well this little girl here
is called our 80-inch machine the big
big dog okay the big big dog yeah yeah
yeah
we brought out the big dog the great
thing about this is you can customize it
to whatever you want
this is a stencil so let's hit the gas
there
by the way my nickname you've two chains
i'm two gems
shut up man steve you crazy stay
great so look man you put the
biodegradable
good soap solution soap solution mix it
with water
helium and nitrogen it's the only things
that
are pushing you don't even need power
there's no electricity here
there's no electricity here is there
the wind going the wind going this way
all right let's see
come on man i'm the best watch how that
one go
oh it's like you called it i'm telling
you you called him there you go
i'm gonna go right there oh he's crank
hey you want it hey come on
you're the big dog let's go lozie get
over there you see it go over you got it
you see it let me wipe your wand off
yeah yeah oh
you heard that on screen before no
just keep it oh you can do all of them
yeah yeah that's all i'm saying
so keep keep it keep it nice and smooth
oh that is
good form like butter man i do this
that is just the coolest thing in the
world
[Music]
and so now you're telling your girl say
look up babe i love you
how much would something like this cost
it's pretty most expensivist
this machine here is about nine thousand
dollars the machine is nine grand
yeah this is like a red toy box
i've seen it more like a coffin if i
don't do well
[Music]
[ __ ] all right this one can be a little
difficult
no do you want me to do it i can do it
okay here we go
do not stop get that jimmy get that one
that's the one i'm good at everything
could you do this all day
a couple hours
30 minutes it's not bad so yeah like i
said this is the uh the 80 inch there's
a 16 inch
36 48 60.
and how much if i wanted to put the
hearts in the air for my lady
for you yeah hook me up not a damn dime
thank you man new stencil alert what do
we have will you marry me will you marry
me
yep that's nice and we pulled this out
for our world's first marriage proposal
done
in cloud form
hey oh man you're gonna it will
[Music]
you had
[Music]
can you read that
good
[Music]
we do things over the top but we also do
stuff for non-profits we do people who
have lost family members
we do try to take care of the people
that you know maybe don't have the money
to do it or they have a cause that uh
you know really speaks to us well i'm i
just lost a home boy today
i'm gonna send some love up for
absolutely this right here is for my
homeboy
nipsey hustle this is on a really
serious note it ain't worth dying
so i want to put some some hearts in
there for my partner
i wish i didn't have to do this
i wish i didn't get the bad news i'm
sorry to hear that man
i want to tell you i love you homie god
bless your family and everything
this is the most expensive it's like
shotgun weddings and stuff but this
is this is for my partner man i
appreciate y'all
keep locked
[Music]
you